[Musique]
vous n'aimez pas qui vous êtes vous
cherchez à vous revaloriser une seule
méthode exercices physiques
développement intellectuel don de soi
même et méditation vous avez du temps à
perdre avec ces simagrées
moi non plus pourquoi s'épuiser à
devenir une meilleure personne quand on
peut le prouver la même satisfaction en
rabaissant simplement les autres des
milliers de personnes ont déjà choisi de
se revaloriser en dénigrant les autres
pourquoi pas vous dénigrez d'accord mais
qui pourquoi pas moi ou moi ou bien moi
ou encore mois avec victime express jeu
sera la personne qui correspond le mieux
à vos critères de détestation j'aimerais
bien quelqu'un qui porte des pantacourts
c'est possible robot je pense que ça
devrait être dans nos cordes
pas besoin de raisons valables c'est le
résultat qui compte et si vous avez
besoin d aide
nous sommes là pour vous conseiller
sinon je peux vous proposer quelqu'un
qui a des goûts musicaux un peu
différents des vôtres s'annonce bien
c'est bien comme ça je vais pouvoir
juger toute sa personnalité à partir de
ça vous êtes un geek un nerd pas de
problème notre service est présent sur
les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant j'étais pas bien je me trouvais
nul puis j'ai découvert victime express
maintenant je me trouve toujours pas
terrible mais je trouve les autres pire
bon pied
[Musique]